so Donald Trump is our president I wish
a [ __ ] would send me back to
Korea I dare you to Dodd dare you to try
I please don't I love this country hey
what is going on you do [ __ ] my
sweating like a [ __ ] man got it
what's wrong now recently a subscriber
asked I have been doing really well with
my life but it seems the more successful
I get the people around me start to hate
me even more whenever they are
successful in what they're doing
I feel happy for them but they don't do
the same for me is there something wrong
with me oh my god no I know that that
but but that you're talking about listen
here dude I feel you that is like every
other person on this mother [ __ ]
earth listen just to make you feel
better yesterday I read a science
article that stated that till this day
people cannot figure out why when
somebody else does well there's this
thing that tends to grow up their ass I
cannot get a clap top please always a
bit whoa it's that concept of you could
be friends with someone as long as
you're not successful or you're not more
successful than them you're feeling like
[ __ ] yep that's my boy this [ __ ] trust
me you are not alone everybody in their
life will eventually find their groove a
fake Hermes that will stick around you
until they start feeling shitty about
themselves and start developing in a
very already complex that's a big
[ __ ] word because hopefully you're
the type of friend that was saying to
yourself that I'm gonna do well i'ma
bring my homies up with me but what they
took it as was you sink you are soda
better than me huh first of all I don't
know what the [ __ ] you're saying let's
start with that yes there is a certain
type of person in this world that in
order for them to feel better about
their position in life they have to
bring down somebody else and talk [ __ ]
about what they're doing in their life
and let me clarify something before I
continue
what is it hand plebbit you can have an
opinion on anything and that's perfectly
fine and that means whether it's
positive or it's negative that's up to
you you could have those thoughts but if
the only way for you to feel good about
yourself is to wake up every morning and
[ __ ] on someone else's success look in
the mirror and say hey nobody loves me
no what I'm trying to say is that you
are a sad individual biggest apps I fail
to understand why someone else's success
especially somebody who is close to you
and is supposed to be your personal
friend hurts you as an individual
why Vegas taps just because somebody
else is doing well and the things that
they are doing doesn't mean that you're
doing shitty in what you're doing
or if you aren't progressing in your
life use the success of your friends as
motivation to do better because I
guarantee you if you have the time to
sit there gripe and complain and talk
[ __ ] about somebody else's stuff then
I'm pretty sure you're not doing [ __ ]
with your life so get off your [ __ ]
lazy ass and do something now let me
give you an example of what I mean I'm a
youtuber that did not go into vine now
what I started doing bi and I got a bit
of a following I had like a 100k
followers or something like that and I
didn't like the platform I couldn't
stick with it I hated it now if you ask
me now do I regret not doing vine and
continuing with my following no I have
no regrets at all and the reason why is
because you know it's being deleted in
your face [ __ ] all those great six
second videos are now gonna go to
Instagram where they're a full [ __ ]
minute yeah thank you for that by the
way this by the way is every vine video
ever now holy [ __ ] mama is that a booty
put that [ __ ] were you looking at my
girl's booty at excessive gunshot my
good man I'm a beat yo ass cuz I'm her
boyfriend and a gunshot right here
that's my [ __ ] opinion and I'm
allowed to have it
but I will never say about any of those
people who are doing these type of stuff
and doing well in their scene does not
deserve every [ __ ] bit of success
that they have as a consumer of the
content I can have an opinion about it
whether I like it or not or why I don't
like it or why I hate their success is
[ __ ] well deserved it's not what I'm
doing and it doesn't take away from my
success people have to learn how to
congratulate others that's what it is
are they more successful than me do
people know them a lot more now do they
make a [ __ ] ton more money yes but when
I heard so anybody out there if this is
you you have to ask yourself a few
questions if I was happy would I have
the time to hate someone else's joy a
joy that doesn't hurt others or
perpetuate any type of negativity do I
have to crush that to make me feel good
listen happy people don't do that [ __ ]
happy people are too busy being happy
you can't be walking around looking like
a puckered [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm ambience
bugs I'll walk around giving people
compliments and hugs for no [ __ ]
reason
hey no spitting oh nice your ballsack is
nice and tight coochy looking right at
the end of the day if you are doing
great things in this world and
accomplishing things without stepping on
others you ain't got to worry about
people like that because here's the
thing for people who do this you can go
ahead and sit there and talk your way
out of not being sad and realizing that
you're in a terrible position in your
life that you have to do that to others
but that [ __ ] will disappear one day and
that realization is gonna hit you like a
[ __ ] Rhino dick in the face I was
doing so well so my friend what I'm
telling you is be positive and show your
success through your positivity and that
will in turn affect others and you will
surround yourself with those type of
people as well just be careful for
sharks careful people out there that
will put you down and if they do call
Davis o up and i'ma call somebody else
who's bigger than me who knows how to
fight who's a lot stronger and is not a
[ __ ] I got you back from a distance oh
man my self-esteem is low take a snaps
that's what you think you're like better
than me or something or level it with a
Wacka cut to what every morning and whoa
pick a snap on that one and this is that
look as cool as I thought it would